bonsoir un nouveau générique vous venez
de le voir un nouveau sigle vous le
voyez et un nouveau nom la télévision de
service public s'est habillé de neuf
depuis ce matin france 2 et france 3
c'est un changement d'image mais c'est
aussi beaucoup plus que ça alain chabod
1 3 bleus avec le mot france en blanc
inscrit sur le haut du chiffre c'est
désormais le nouveau logo de la chaîne
adieu fr3 bonjour france 3 depuis ce
matin toute la signalétique du réseau a
changé caméra véhicule l'équipe de
reportage mais aussi ce qu'on appelle
l'habillage de la chaîne c'est-à-dire
les nouveaux génériques et autres jingle
informations programme météo publicité
un relookage total qui correspond à la
nouvelle image que veulent donner les
télévision de service public dans le
paysage audiovisuel français
la naissance de france télévisions est
marquée à la fois par un renouveau de
l'envelope et du contenu et exprime une
ambition stratégique
le retour du service public au premier
plan les années 90 seront les années du
service public un nouveau look qui
traduit une meilleure complémentarité
des programmes entre france 2 et france
3 bref un service public plus offensif
avec france télévisions ce sont les
chaînes privées qui sont en ligne de
mire ainsi le logo de france 2 et france
3 se décline désormais en bleu blanc et
rouge tf1 n'a plus le monopole des
couleurs nationales